how many builders in the room
right builders holy [ __ ] that's a lot
okay so
how many how many breakers
okay no how many people do
security uh
for a living here is there any other
security people in the room
yeah this is what it feels like to be at
a at a developer conference as a
security person this is really exciting
so i'm going to talk about
it's broken
i didn't do that
all right
that was great unexpected
so i'm going to talk on builders
versus breakers if anyone is scared of
scared of talking about feelings uh
please leave now it's a non-technical
talk if you're looking for live coding
that's elsewhere if you're looking for
odays that's elsewhere we're going to
talk about builders versus breakers uh
hi
everybody i'm adam
uh you can find me on twitter uh adam
underscore baldwin lyft security node
security and github as evil packet
i am the cso chief security officer as
well as the chief of software operations
for and yet
and i am the team lead at lyft security
as a and yet
sort of
project
so that puts me a builder
on one hand
and breaker
on the
other
and wedges me firmly in between
these
these two communities
and
it's the topic of builders versus
breakers has
has tormented me for a number of years
in my career
and i didn't realize at first it sort of
snuck up on me and uh
i
i approached uh
i approached things as a typical breaker
would i only looked at my perspective
early on in security i looked at my
perspective of
of how i
thought of of
of security problems and how i
approached them and so what i'm going to
talk about today is basically all the
things that i screwed up as a breaker
and try to give
the builders a perspective
of that
and hopefully will come away from it
understanding a little bit more of
both the
builder perspective and the breaker
perspective and how we can both actually
work
better together
by understanding each other a little bit
more
and again through my failures and then
through some just ideas that i have
so
how many of you
have you've met a lot of a lot of people
at the conference right a lot of new
people has anyone walked up to you and
said
hey uh that shirt
yeah that that that shirt that hat
doesn't really work on you you should
you should you should wear a different
hat it's better shape for your head and
for your face right no nobody walks up
to you and introduces themselves that
way right
that's that's tends to be how security
people
do it how how breakers do it we this is
how i met adam bralt the uh the founder
of and yet uh five years ago and this is
one this is when the start of my
thinking
uh
about this topic um
sort of started i i sent him an email
and i said fix your captcha so the value
isn't actually uh in the form
it was insecure put the put it in the
session and check the post uh here's a
mutual friend of ours that's how i
introduce myself uh
you know in hindsight that's that's
pretty crass that's that's not really a
good way to start a relationship
with somebody it's like hey
your stuff's broken yeah do something
about it whatever i don't really care um
so that was sort of the beginning of my
thinking on the subject uh introduce
myself
and uh
so that's one thing just kind of keep
this in mind as we as we go along this
is the start of that
um another project that i that i worked
on uh was evilpacket.net
and i thought i was reporting these web
vulnerabilities to to to builders to
developers to projects and
you know i was getting like nobody cared
nobody's responding to respond might fix
it and i thought maybe
maybe that understanding was founded in
not or that misunderstanding was was
founded in um
they didn't understand the impact
developers didn't understand the impact
of what those vulnerabilities
what could cause right and
turns out that's that's that's wrong and
it sort of like
ended up being when i look back on it it
was effective in getting things fixed
and
sure some people did
learn some
things about
vulnerabilities and exploits and
whatever
but it was a very negative way to do it
and i'm going to talk specifically about
some of those in a minute um just kind
of keep
keep these in mind as we as we go
uh
ryan are you are you here
all right so this one's this one's for
you back in in
as a
as a a breaker i thought it was a great
idea uh to start going to developer
conferences
you guys
see i said it right there
builders are my audience right from a
security perspective i want to talk
to you
it's really hard for me not to say to
you guys and separate myself so
at
jsconf in portland uh
ryan gave me the feedback during my talk
i kept saying you guys this you guys
that
point point point
you know rant rant rant typical
breaker mindset
and
you know i was given very direct
feedback like
you know i don't remember the exact
tweet i couldn't find it but
it was something you know something of
the you know this guy's saying you guys
looks like a lot like stop
and it it's really really really
impacted my thing like
those two words and that feedback i
don't think you realize how just how
much it's had an impact on my
on my thinking about the interaction
between the two communities and when
you're speaking if you as a as a builder
as a developer if you're going to go
speak at a security event remember
be a part of that community because
because you are we we really are we
really have a
like relationship that that is very
dependent on each other
don't alienate yourself like i did like
don't
it was just i missed a huge opportunity
to connect with people and get my
message across
because i just put up that wall
i'm an outsider looking in i'm not you
know i'm just saying blah blah rant so
again
uh keep that in mind and thank you
so let's tell a little bit a story uh
about a specific organization uh that
will kind of demonstrate
uh some of the things that i'm talking
about
uh basecamp classic 37 signals was the i
found a vulnerability in base camp in
which you could take over any account
this is you know a few years back
and i let 37 signals no it's actually
the second video i published on evil
packet
and
during that process i contacted support
and i wrote him a nice email
i don't i i tried to look at him i
didn't have it and i basically said
here's the problem i got a response back
from support that said
basically
you know our clients like to be able to
do this like do we put javascript in the
pages and whatever and basically what
they said is that it's a feature
and
this is
was my answer crosstalk scripting is not
a feature and i made a video about it
and
put it on the internet
and they got raked over the coals
in hindsight
feeling wise i
felt
terrible
for what
what was being uh what was what was
going on there
but
we'll get to it uh now
feelings
so let's let's talk about what's
happening
during both
on both sides
when these things are are reported
so you know imagine yourself as
as the developer as the builder in this
scenario i want you to really
think hard about how you
would feel
so as the breaker this is how i feel
i get
an enormous adrenaline high
from finding soft you know security bugs
in your software
i love it i get
so i do this thing at work like i skip
down the hall and i like like do a jig
and and
as the co-worker is going to test i i
skip and holler and jump and get excited
and i'm happy
i'm happy to find a flaw in what you did
and
that's most security people they get
really excited they're like
they just get
just pumped up
what happens on the other side when i
tell
the the developer about that flaw
what happens
is they feel
right
you get the you get the exact opposite
reaction
and this this realization that i've had
that that it's it's actually it's
causing
anxiety if you don't know how to handle
the problem
you have immediate anxiety about how do
i address
this problem
you might be pissed off that i pointed
out your flaw who wants
wants their stuff paraded around the
internet that they had this flaw right
you're pointing out mistakes or the the
the breakers point mistakes the builder
has made it's it's not a nice thing to
have somebody say hey your
stuff's broken
and uh
as a security person we don't have a lot
of vested interest we we uh
we
we basically
don't empathize with your position
we
in traditionally we think of hey this is
the most important thing in the world
we found this vulnerability this is the
thing the security you should take and
fix it right now because i'm excited
about it but you're not
it's the complete opposite plus you have
things like oh i don't know uh
conferences to deal with conferences to
go to and i don't know bugs to fix and
other things to do
besides fix my thing which to me is the
most important thing in the world to you
it might just be a
very small thing
so
instead we can kind of look at it this
way and my son said there needed to be
flags on the castle so on the on the
plane he drew flags on it um
so imagine this one instead that that
extreme
extreme high is like uh
instead looks like a wave and and really
what a breaker's bringing to you
sort of depending on how they bring it
to you they're going to say
uh here's this problem really they're
saying there's a wave coming
there's something coming and it's gonna
hey you got your sandcastler you might
want to you might want to do something
to your castle to protect it to move it
and
if you're prepared for that
communication and you understand
you understand that their intention is
not
to knock your sand castle over
but to actually warn you about something
coming towards your sanecast what's the
beach had to make sand castle analogy
it's is
if you understand that that's their
intention
it's going to reduce
that negative aspect that negative
feeling that you have
when that when you get when you have
that thing that problem reported to you
when you when you have that when you
have that experience
it actually becomes a more becomes a
more positive experience
so
how can we work better together and i
love this because
you know we're builders and breakers can
work together and should
we rely very heavily on each other
breakers if
if you uh
i said it again
if if
it's really hard i
if if builders
don't build anything i don't have
anything to do
as a breaker
and so
so we need
you we need we need builders and
builders
need the feedback of breakers because
they think differently they they they
have that different opinion a different
different perspective
so
what's what's the biggest thing here
communication right
it's it's it's really all about
communication between the builders and
the breakers
my coworker stephanie meyer
who wrote this
this morning got published
about listening this this applies to
both sides when we listen
really listen we reveal respect support
understanding
and empathy
we also possess the power to impart a
renewed confidence
clarity and a sense that
everything is going to be
okay
when we listen well
so
let's give some thoughts on how we can
listen better and how we can communicate
better let's go back to the base camp
uh classic story because that's not the
end they didn't just get raked over the
coals and everything okay that's where
it stopped
what happened was is they they responded
by
understanding
that this was gonna happen again
that that they were gonna have somebody
else report something to them they were
going to have to deal with
breakers
and so they built a security response
process
they made a page that said we appreciate
your concern we appreciate the breakers
they're trying to understand the breaker
perspective and understand that that
what we're offering to them is of some
value to me that that makes me actually
that makes me
actually that feels good makes it feel
valuable for for what i'm providing and
makes me want to go a little bit more of
an effort
put more effort in
they uh they said here's how here's
here's our expectations
for tracking and disclosing security
issues
right
here's here's what you can expect for
communication such and thanks for
working with us and we're going to put
your name on this list so you get some
uh
you get some credit out of it because
that's the motivation of a lot of
breakers right the people getting paid
to do a lot of
consulting work don't have time to work
on random stuff and just throw
stuff out there
the ones that are have the time to do
that are the ones trying to make a name
for themselves
they're working on they're working on it
for the ego for the credit so they can
build their resume and they can build
their skills in the security community
and whether it's right or wrong they're
going to play with your apps
that's what they're going to do
uh so they give them some credit because
it gives them it gives them something to
to hold on to and and feel good about
so as a developer what uh
you know what can i do as a developer
for projects you can we've got
contributor.md we've got readme right
why not security.md
i want to add to your projects how you
want issues reported to you
because
unfortunately
based on the relationship of the builder
and the breaker and the responsibility
for the project you have a lot of the
communication onus
uh
on yourself as a builder
you have you have way more
responsibility
and you're gonna get these things logged
over and you don't know how they're
gonna come in so try to
try to
put it out there and how you want these
reported to you
what are some of the expectations that
this person will receive you're gonna
respond 24 hours just
it doesn't have to be detailed or
complex uh and put a list of humans or
put you know people that have
contributed
thoughts
bugs security bugs whatever
give them some credit
we know a lot of open source projects
can't you can't give them cash because
it's not a big bounty program right yeah
maybe some swag or you know a mention is
that's great for their their for what
they're looking for
if you want a good example of this look
at the amber
security policy
and how they do things it's it's a it's
a great baseline for for what you could
include
it's pretty detailed and it goes it's
based on a lot of security community
research and things like that go check
it out
one other thing you can do is
self-disclosure vulnerabilities
who wants to do that
that's that's a hard thing to do it's a
hard thing for us to
as developers to just put our flaws out
there instead of just patching it a
little commit message throwing in the
repo
i'm going to talk about a project here
in a little bit that i'd like if you're
writing node apps i'd love you to
disclose to because we've got a really
interesting
project going on
and actually handling a security failure
or you know a problem
properly and publicly can build trust
there's a great example uh from a client
of mine github and they do a great job
of handling these things whenever they
have a problem
right
they disclose
a ton of detail they write a blog post
about here's what happened here's what
we're going to do about it here's the
technical bits and we all learn from it
and they they they do this because they
realize they're in the uh they're in a
position of technical leadership in the
community and
chances are
so are many of you
in your different
areas as a builder
so you can lead in the same example
in the same way
so now i'm going to talk about a project
that i started based on
what i've been learning over the past
five years of these and as as one thing
that i hadn't mentioned yet is that
all of those all those things those
failures of mine and the closeness that
i've been to and yet and a lot of other
development teams
have got me to
really empathize with builders and
the feelings that you go through
when
when you have something reported to you
it's really really hard for me now to
know to have
to have these feelings and and empathy
to drop an oday about a product
i feel like a complete [ __ ] if i did
that
right i would just feel
i'd feel horrible and it doesn't help
anything it's a very negative thing to
do uh there's a there's an interesting
example out there right now a paypal
paypal's got a bug bounty program
there's a 17 year old
that try to disclose a bug to them
and
he's not old enough to get a bounty
so he just dropped and he just dropped
it on full disclosure and said oh here
you go they actually made it worse by
not really
trying to work through the problem with
they're just like whatever it's just
simple now we got the information
just go away
they actually it actually turned into a
lot much larger wave
than
than using it as a sort of early warning
so
now that i've covered all the stuff that
i forgot to talk about earlier let's
talk about the node security project
who's here has heard about the node
security project
wow awesome
so the node security project is
something that uh
as i as
as
as a cso and and yet my job is to care
about building secure software and i
started by
trying to figure out how
how are people going to try to break our
product and bank how
how are we gonna find uh who's gonna
report flaws in it and how how can we
attack it what it came down to was
well there's this npm thing we're
trusting a lot of modules we're trusting
a lot of third-party code and so we
started uh started looking into problems
well we you know we we had one thing uh
where you know the password hashes were
uh disclosed from npm
right people might have heard of that
and had their change your password on
npm so all those were disclosed uh we
added cross-site request forgery
protection to the the npm site i've had
a lot of discussion with uh isaac
you know about uh the security of npm
and so there's been a lot of
conversations between builder and
breaker community there that that that
led up to this particular project and
and some of the things that the
securityman pm so i thought what's the
next layer
well what's the next node security
project is we need to uh check out the
security of the modules the things that
we trust right the things that all of
the builders
doing node projects
trust
so uh it's an experiment to bridge
the security community with the
builder community we're taking both of
these communities and mashing them
together and trying to get them to play
nice and i really really really was
nervous about how
we were going to have these researches
and how we were going to handle the
organization it turns out it's not very
hard the ones that have come on board
are really really excited
to work with builders and they
understand
that we don't have to be you know
[ __ ] to to get cha to make change
and have have good progress
here's some major contributors to date
um you know adam brault from our team
nathan lafreniere bear michael rogers mr
daniel shaw
neil poole is a security researcher
luca caratoni stephen rivas who's a node
developer he's building he's helping us
build tools he doesn't really know
anything about security but we rely so
heavily on on builders that can help us
build tools that
our our mindsets we're not that's not
that's not what we do so we have to like
static analysis and things like that to
do it really efficiently and well we're
relying uh in our workflow we're relying
on builders to help us
uh arlo brought and jacobo tarantino
again another another builder that's
helping us build our our portal to
disclose advisories and things like that
our workflow
so what are our goals uh we're going to
audit every module
which is pretty much absolutely a crazy
thing isaac said it's a massive
ambitious potentially ocean ocean
boiling undertaking and it is we figured
out a way to do it efficiently
and if you want to know some of the
technical bits i can go into that sort
of after
but we're going to order it you know say
31 000. that number's gone up since i
fixed this last night
um
and then we're going to fix
the broken modules
but traditional security projects just
go
your thing's broken your thing's broken
go fix it
we're gonna report the issues we find as
as best we can we're gonna try to do it
privately can't do that try to get a
hold of with a maintainer we can't do
that we'll end up putting an issue
in in the repository
stop texting me
um
and we're going to try to do it in a
very
polite and positive way we're trying not
to be
like all the history of of that we're
trying to break out of that mold and
we're going to send pull requests we're
not going to publish an advisory without
something fixed if a module is two years
old we find a vulnerability in the
maintainer doesn't want to do it
and
or
got it you know doesn't exist anymore or
whatever we're going to supply a patch
pull request
all right thanks felix
that's that's the difference we're
trying to cross that line
and fix stuff
instead of just cause problems
so here's an example that
of communication uh on hubot github
so their client we tried to report
internally they said go ahead and go
ahead and put it in the repo and the
maintainers will take care of it we
published it and at midnight
this the issue was just closed silently
so we put this vulnerability in there
issue was closed silently no comment uh
one of our researchers said i think you
may have closed the wrong issue it's a
small story the code for email.coffee is
still vulnerable
not taking an attacking tone thinking
that maybe there was a mistake
making sure that we communicate not just
say well all right we're just going to
publish an advisory whatever and be done
with it no so tom says um
in close the correct issue hebot is
running a trusted environment if you
don't trust people you allow access to
ubot i think you should stop at uh you
know allowing them access to hubot
we didn't particularly agree with that
but again we didn't we didn't take an
attacking tone uh neil
neil did a great job of communicating
this it's a
great example of what we're trying to do
i appreciate that
he acknowledges because it's true if you
have trusted people sure he says i
appreciate that but hubot is open source
there's no guarantee that hubot will be
run in a trusted environment
uh and also even if you even if that
guarantee did exist just because you
give somebody access to you bot doesn't
mean you want them running arbitrary
code in this case
on your server right
at the end instead of arguing because we
could just continue to banter back and
forth
this fix should be really fairly
straightforward would you be willing to
consider merging a pull request
i think the next day he just we whipped
up a patch
sent it merged done
didn't have to argue
didn't have to fight over it didn't have
to it's just done so it's fantastic
and then we're going to publish the
results we're not publishing anything
that does not have a fix
for it
so we're going to try really really hard
to to have those pull requests have
those patches uh here's an example of
just a few that we found already that
have gone through the pipeline
how you can contribute
is uh
is
basically uh all detailed at
nodesecurity.io
i need people to do patches there's
there's issues we have marked there that
says need patch
and
i don't necessarily i'm not the best
person to write those so i need help in
that area and it's something that
somewhere you could contribute usually
they're just quick little one-offs it
probably takes somebody that's a good
good builder 15-20 minutes maybe you
know less
it take me you know okay i got to figure
out how to write javascript again today
yeah
uh quick recap so
each
we have we have a relationship
builders and breakers that rely upon
each other we all have
uh and need to respect and understand
the feelings of the other of the other
party and realize that that we both do
have good intention
we have to communicate
and listen
effectively
try to be nice and positive about it
this this we can break out of that mold
we can do things differently
some
we have an amazing community
and
it's okay
it's okay it's okay to screw up like
there's gonna be researchers that are
gonna be jerks to you and there's gonna
be builders that don't listen to to
researchers and breakers
and we just have to fight through that
and remind those parties that
that
hey here's how we could work through
this and don't don't immediately take
the attacking tone
don't immediately
dismiss something that a breaker says we
have good intentions both sides
and
if you want more information want to
chat about it i'll be available later i
also have node security stickers because
when you put a lock on something it's
more secure right and
that's it
you